y
[Música]
el gobierno estadounidense envió una
comisión a haití para investigar el
secuestro de 17 misioneros
norteamericanos ocurrido el fin de
semana pasado el fbi colabora con las
pesquisas mientras que grupos de
ciudadanos se declararon en huelga
nacional contra la ola de secuestros
tenemos reportes de puerto príncipe
se cumplen dos años del estallido social
en chile contra la desigualdad en una de
las mayores economías de américa latina'
en santiago miles se manifiestan en
conmemoración del inicio de la
movilización social que dejó 30
fallecidos en los meses que se prolongó
y que derivó en la asamblea que
actualmente trabaja en una nueva
constitución tenemos reporte desde la
capital chilena
el empresario colombo-venezolano alexa
compareció en una primera audiencia ante
la justicia estadounidense que lo
investiga por presunto lavado de dinero
su extradición provocó que caracas
detuviera los diálogos con la oposición
y eeuu criticó la medida analizamos en
esta emisión
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos este
informativo en haití una comisión del
fbi viajó a este país centroamericano
para colaborar en la investigación del
secuestro de 17 misioneros 16 de eeuu y
uno canadiense
ocurrido el fin de semana como protesta
ante la oleada de violencia que vive la
nación grupos de ciudadanos se unieron a
una huelga nacional marina sardiña tiene
los detalles
eeuu investiga el secuestro de 17
ciudadanos norteamericanos en haití el
pasado sábado un grupo criminal relató a
los misioneros y sus familiares entre
ellos cinco niños cuando regresaban a la
capital puerto príncipe de visitar un
orfanato state department el
departamento de estado tiene como parte
de un pequeño equipo que está ahora en
el terreno que ha sido enviado a haití
para trabajar estrechamente con las
autoridades haitianas en este asunto
onstar seguiremos trabajando con el
gobierno canadiense dado que una de las
víctimas es canadiense y con nuestros
socios interinstitucionales córners en
el último año haití entró en una espiral
de inseguridad violencia crisis
económica y política este lunes las
calles de la capital habitualmente
caóticas estaban tranquilas mientras
miles de trabajadores declararon dos
días de huelga nacional liderada por los
transportistas debido a la falta de
seguridad en la isla que afecta a sus
precarias economías
no módulo en todos los países del mundo
la seguridad es el primer bien público
significa que cuando estás en un país
que no tiene seguridad social un grupo
de bandas te obliga a desplazarte te
secuestran violan a tu hija cuando no
podemos comer también es una inseguridad
apoyo la huelga al cien por cien por el
derecho a que la vida cambie
en los últimos meses las bandas
criminales han puesto el foco en
iglesias y grupos religiosos a cambio de
extorsiones el principal sospechoso del
rapto de los misioneros 400 magos
también secuestró a 10 personas el
pasado abril vamos ahora a chile porque
se cumplen dos años desde el inicio del
estallido social de 2019 en el que más
de 30 personas perdieron la vida cientos
de ciudadanos se movilizaron en santiago
al tiempo que la convención encargada de
redactar la nueva carta magna dio inicio
al debate de fondo de las normas
constitucionales lo que supone un hito
para el proceso constituyente desde la
capital chilena nuestra corresponsal
patricia luna nos dio más detalles
si le vuelve a salir a las calles en una
jornada en la que se conmemoran dos años
del estallido social del 18 de octubre
la fecha que cambió la historia de chile
para siempre las manifestaciones se han
sucedido a lo largo de la capital y de
todo el país desde temprano en la mañana
la asociación de estudiantes secundarios
se manifestaba a cerca del costanera
center en el centro comercial más
importante del país y recordaba que
fueron ellos al saltarse los torniquetes
del metro los que iniciaron un poco esta
revuelta social conmemoran el hecho
volviéndose a saltar torniquetes de otra
estación de metro son diversas las
manifestaciones que han sucedido a lo
largo del país muchas de ellas se han
concentrado en torno al edificio de
donde se encuentra la convención
constituyente es en este lugar en el
entorno de la convención constituyendo
este hondo también se escribe una nueva
página de la historia de chile y es que
la convención constituyente salida de
todo este proceso de revuelta social
inicia hoy mismo la escritura de una
nueva carta que va
de destinada a reemplazar la heredada
por la dictadura de augusto pinochet en
1980 hablamos con algunos de los
convencionales y constitucionales que
nos explicaron la importancia de este
momento histórico que un día
para conmemorar cuantos chiles como
decimos nosotros de expertos en este
momento veo que se están durmiendo son
pocos la gente que se está manifestando
espero que sigan saliendo a manifestarse
pero pacíficamente y que crean en el
trabajo que se está haciendo en la
convención porque en el trabajo que se
está haciendo acá dentro es un trabajo
arduo donde si queremos cambio donde si
vamos a tratar de lograr ese cambio en
esta constitución es espera que miles de
personas acudan también en el día de hoy
para conmemorar esta fecha que cambio
chile para siempre y donde todavía están
los reclamos de las diversas demandas
sociales entre ellas pensión educación
salud que todavía no se atienden también
en un momento en que dos años después
chile está más cerca de la impunidad que
de la verdad y la justicia entra en
cuanto a las graves violaciones a los
derechos humanos ocurridas en el
contexto del estallido social entre
ellas a las más de 500
450 personas que sufrieron trauma ocular
en otras noticias el empresario colombo
venezolano álex saab intermediario de
los negocios internacionales del
gobierno de nicolás maduro asistió hoy a
su primera audiencia en una corte de
miami eeuu donde se le acusa de siete
cargos por lavado de dinero y uno de
conspiración como consecuencia de su
extradición desde cabo verde el
presidente maduro detuvo los diálogos
con la oposición y aseguró este lunes
que evaluará qué va a pasar con el
futuro de las conversaciones que se
llevaban a cabo en mexico washington a
través del portavoz del departamento de
estado crítico de la medida para
analizar este tema nos acompaña josé
vicente carrasquero él es doctor en
ciencias políticas y profesor de la
universidad simón bolívar en venezuela
bienvenido france24 la suspensión de los
diálogos a quien favorece y a quien
perjudica
bueno perjudica evidentemente a los
venezolanos que estábamos a punto de
comenzar el proceso de donde
precisamente se retornaba a la agenda
social en la claridad que hay que tomar
para comenzar a resolver los graves
problemas que viven los venezolanos esto
no es un asunto del gobierno oposición y
asunto de la mayoría de la población en
venezuela que están sometidas las
condiciones de vida es bastante precaria
y que bueno esta mesa en esta reunión
particular y es acá va a ocuparse de ese
tema y lo que queda claro es que la
prioridad de manning no es esa la
prioridad de maduro es jugar a la
política la prioridad de maduro es
generar su voz de protesta o lo que
quiera con el señor que está preso pero
hay ningún momento antepone a eso la
cantidad de personas que están sufriendo
en varios servicios de salud o de largo
servicio de educación
seguridad no tiene electricidad no tiene
entonces este esa distribución de
prioridades pone en tela de juicio la
preocupación que tiene el gobierno
maduro por lo presionando desde su
perspectiva la reacción del palacio de
miraflores de suspender estos diálogos
es algo que sorprende o ya es parte de
una dinámica habitual del presidente
maduro
hay que decir que hay que una especie de
copia casi que al carmen de los procesos
de discusión entre las farc y el
gobierno colombiano
es un mecanismo de presión que al final
lo que hace es elevar una voz de
protesta porque tú estás suspendiendo su
participación en un diálogo que como que
es culpando a alguien que no tiene
posibilidad de resolver lo que tú
quieres que se resuelva y ahí está la
extradición muy grave de las única si la
oposición tuviese oportunas
posibilidades de resolver eso bueno
entonces uno entiende que se suspendan
la participación del gobierno de la mesa
pero que está suspendiendo y ni los
venezolanos ni la oposición tiene
posible alguna deliberar
y hacer que sharp es participe en la
mesa de negociación bueno y qué se puede
esperar para el futuro de alexa ahora
que está en manos de la justicia
estadounidense
bueno el asunto de alexa es que ahorita
está bajo un sistema de justicia
garantista el serbio en el proceso de
presentación eligieron sus derechos se
le leyeron cómo eran los procedimientos
y eso de alguna forma le va a permitir
probar si verdaderamente es inocente en
eeuu no le van a inventar en carne sino
al cabo no está ejerciendo una acción
contra
saab es básicamente porque tiene pruebas
tendrá la oportunidad de dejar de
ejercer y si están es y es tandil de
esas culpas entonces saldrá favorecido
evidentemente la experiencia nos indica
que los estados unidos.los se meten en
este tipo de juicios y no tiene pruebas
suficientes en contra del acusado en
todo seguro tiende a pensar que él va a
ir a un juicio tuvo una situación
bastante delicada en su contra
bueno señor carrasquero pues a usted
muchísimas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros aquí en france
24 en otras noticias la corte
interamericana de derechos humanos
determinó que el estado colombiano es
responsable
internacionalmente por la violación de
los derechos a la integridad personal la
libertad personal la honra la dignidad y
la libertad de expresión de la
periodista colombiana jineth bedoya la
condena se produce por el secuestro de
la comunicadora a manos de paramilitares
ocurrido en el año 2000 durante el cual
la reportera fue torturada y abusada
sexualmente
el presidente de guandú que aseguró que
la sentencia será acatada en su
totalidad
una vez más el estado colombiano rechaza
toda agresión física y psicológica
contra las mujeres quien él bedoya jamás
debió ser secuestrada y torturada la
sentencia de la corte internacional de
derechos humanos se cumplirá en su
totalidad como siempre colombia lo ha
hecho el embajador de francia en belarús
abandonó el país tras una petición de
salida de minsk el enfrentamiento
diplomático se produce tras la negativa
de la unión europea a reconocer la
victoria de alexander lukashenko en las
elecciones del 9 de agosto cuando fue
elegido para un sexto mandato en medio
de denuncias de fraude de una brutal
represión de opositores veamos más
el embajador de francia en belarús
nicola de lacoste abandonó minsk bajo
circunstancias complicadas el gobierno
de alexandr lukashenko no dio ninguna
razón pero de lacoste dijo no haberse
reunido con lukashenko para entregarle
copias de sus credenciales tras haber
sido nombrado para el puesto el año
pasado
permíteme enviarles hoy un mensaje de
despedida mi esposa y yo lamentablemente
tenemos que dejar belarús como saben
francia no reconoció el resultado de las
elecciones del 9 de agosto de 2020 y no
entregué mis credenciales
la represión de las protestas masivas y
de los opositores tras las elecciones
lleva la unión europea a imponer
sanciones contra belarús lo que se sumó
a la condena a que el ejecutivo
bielorruso ordenara desviar un vuelo
comercial y aterrizar en minsk para
poder detener a un periodista de la
oposición además la atención se está
viendo agravada por la crisis
humanitaria la frontera entre belarús y
polonia y lukashenko enfrenta
acusaciones por trasladar a migrantes
indocumentados a polonia y al báltico
razones por las que el ministro de
asuntos exteriores instó a la unión
europea a sancionar a la aerolínea
nacional de la vía por transportar a los
migrantes
entonces necesitamos aplicar sanciones
más estrictas especialmente si se tiene
en cuenta que belarús y lukashenko
todavía usan la migración como arma y yo
creo que se necesita considerar
seriamente aplicar más presión a
belarús está cada vez más aislado
diplomáticamente y ha expulsado a varios
diplomáticos de su territorio incluidos
los de polonia lituania y letonia
bueno y ahora continuamos con noticias
de alemania porque los liberales del fdp
siguieron a sus posibles socios los
socialdemócratas y los verdes al
ratificar que iniciarán las
negociaciones de coalición para formar
el próximo gobierno con el que se
producirá la salida de la canciller
angela merkel los líderes federales del
fdp y los miembros del parlamento
votaron a favor de iniciar las
negociaciones de las reuniones
exploratorias iniciales que podrían
hacer que el socialdemócrata olaf scholz
sea el nuevo canciller alemán el spd de
centroizquierda y los y ecologistas ya
habían aprobado iniciar conversaciones
a continuación otros hechos que son
noticia en el mundo las fuertes lluvias
registradas el fin de semana en
tailandia causaron nuevas inundaciones
luego de que una reserva se desbordara y
otras alcanzaran casi el máximo de
capacidad en la provincia de su favor y
en el centro del país las
precipitaciones también han golpeado el
norte de esta nación forzando a las
autoridades a establecer planes de
evacuación de ser necesarios
al menos tres personas perdieron la vida
y otras tres están desaparecidas en
vietnam tras las inundaciones causadas
por las lluvias del fin de semana en el
norte y el centro del país numerosas
viviendas fueron arrastradas por el agua
decenas de carreteras quedaron
bloqueadas por deslizamientos y las
clases fueron suspendidas
en india las inundaciones y
deslizamientos registrados en el estado
de kerala dejan al menos 21 muertos la
armada ha sido la encargada de realizar
las operaciones de rescate tras la caída
de árboles y la salida de varios ríos de
su cauce
llegamos hacia el final de esta emisión
a ustedes gracias por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros que hay más en
france 24
[Música]